I don't even know where to begin with
this horrible story and how sad I am but
uh my dear dear friend Ralph Ralph of
course who calls into the show all the
time and Ralph who has been at my side
for so many years has died and I tell
you um it's going to be difficult for me
to get through this obituary if you will
but uh I just have been so sad and so
angry I think this is the toughest part
of loving someone when you lose them and
Lord knows I loved Ralph I've probably
been friends with Ralph for maybe 40
years we love to laugh together wherever
we'd be I'd be waiting backstage at
Letterman and I always love to have
Ralph around me because we would giggle
there were days we'd call each other on
the phone and spend hours talking as
George te uh Ralph is the reason I
always start the show with hey now hey
now Ralph was in love with the Larry
Sanders show and every minute he was hey
now it became so infectious that I
started go hey now hey now and every hey
now hey now hey now hey now first of all
when we were on wnbc Ralph used to call
into our show he called in uh his mother
was listening too he was in high school
and this is his first call 1985 we were
on the air Howard can you play the new
uh Connie Francis Christmas song you
want to hear it again yeah my mother
didn't hear it she loves Connie Francis
well she listening now for yeah you want
to talk to her yeah sure hold on what
did my son say that I like Connie
Francis she's not a singer she's not an
Entertainer I got rid of her I thought
she had something to say let me speak to
your mother I don't want to speak to you
you Dopey kid I'm not a Dopey kid man
listen I was on D Letterman too by the
way he never told me he was on Letterman
when was he on Letterman before I even
met him they chose him from the audience
to like ask Larry Bud Melman a question
during a segment what is your name sir
Ral where you from Ralph men Jersy what
do you do for a living uh I work in an
office what kind of office where they do
office work oh one of those
officers uh and your question sir I'd
like to know what the best investments
for the 80s are oh good question best
investments for the 80s you know history
could have been very different if he had
piled up to Letterman Letterman would
have looked like me there you go
Letterman would have had the long hair
and Letterman knew not to become friends
with Ralph I I somehow became friends
with him he was a tremendously talented
guy when I met Ralph we had no budget
and I needed to look like Larry King or
something like that and Ralph would make
these elaborate Prosthetics and I said
you are so talented and and that was the
beginning of our friendship I remember
I'm sitting there on the channel 9 show
he goes you don't look that good on air
like maybe you should grow your hair out
a little bit or maybe your clothes are a
little tight don't wear short sleeves he
started to critique my look and rather
than get offended I said you know work
with me and so he came he he started
cutting my hairir he started uh doing
makeup for me he was do he was a jack of
all trades he's the reason I met Beth he
grabbed you and dragged you out of the
house that night right you didn't want
to go out he made me go to this dinner
party and he was sitting next to Beth he
really had to convince me to come out I
went there and I just had the best night
of my life I met the person I love in
this world the most Beth I know that
Ralph was a true friend of mine because
there was one time I was dating this guy
guy and Ralph knew the guy and then when
we broke up Ralph called me that evening
and I picked up the phone and said hey
Ralph and he was he just said [__] that
guy and then he he was just like you
don't spend a second feeling bad about
this you know and he was just that kind
of guy by way didn't that make you feel
great oh my God I was laughing I was
immediately laughing because it was so
amazing
what are you doing get away from here
Ralph it was Jackie who was giving you a
hard
time get out of here stop
it the bottom line is Ralph was a
trustworthy dear friend who made me
laugh every time I was with him and the
trust and the admiration we had for each
other was genuine let's just say uh rest
in peace Ralphie boy yeah I can't
believe we're saying it but uh this guy
this guy was my man and uh he's like the
brother I never
had